لطال مرتبه اسم شيرين بتاشيرات السفر لكن
ما لا يعلمه الكثيرون انه الاسم يرجع
لقريه صغيره تقع اقصى جنوب الاقسام بريك
تحتضن القريه المتحف الاوروبي الذي يوثق
دورها في توحيد اوروبا من خلال الاتفاقيه
الشهيره التي ابرمت عام
1985 تطل على الضفه الغربيه لنهر في منطقه
وادي موسى شديد الجمال حيث منحدرات مزارع
العنب موقعها الفريد الذي يربط عدد الدول
مثل الفرنسي ولوكسمبرج والمانيا هو الذي
خولها لتشهد توقيع واحد من اشهر
الاتفاقيات الاوروبيه
هذا رغم صغر حجمها وقله عدد سكانها الذين
يبلغون حاليا ما يقرب من 1700 نسمه فقط
ويتحدثون الالمانيه والفرنسيه
والاكسسبورجريه واحيانا الهولنديه في
المقابل يزور القريه كل عام اكثر من
50,000 شخص من كافه انحاء العالم وليس
بعيدا عن قريه شنغن يوجد واحد من اكبر
المتاحف الحربيه في اوروبا المتحف الوطني
للتاريخ العسكري والذي يضم العديد من
مخلفات الحرب العالميه الثانيه الاصليه
[موسيقى]